voicemail number two one nine two david  p here's a voicemail i recieved take a  listen to this hi david nancy in oregon  thank you for your wonderful piece on  the alright unfortunately you won't  reach the undereducated alright with  that wonderful message but at least we  can enjoy it and thanks again by  preaching to the choir it's often a  problem but if you look at our youtube  comment spat we're reaching some people  who aren't already in the choir i think  you've got to thank segment producer  noah Ferguson for that all great piece  great great piece on the alt-right  researched and edited by a segment  producer Noah Ferguson all right I'm out  of time no time to tell you what's on  the bonus show but it's a good one david  pakman.com slash membership to sign up  sign up right now and you will have  access in 30 seconds to the world-famous  bonus show we will speak to you that